[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
ان هو بيميل لجمهوريين والشيوخ حائر لكن
حقيقه وحيده اكيده في التجديد النصفي لم
يظهر المد الاحمر
حقيقه التصويت لم تخالف ثوابت النساء
والاقلليات من حزنه للازرق والرجال
والامريكيون الاصليون هواهم احمر
[تصفيق]
مولود ترامب لم يحققوا كل اماله كاريك قد
تنصفه في ارينا وديسانتس صنيعته يستدعيه
للحلبه
لدينا ايضا في العربيه 360
وجوهنا صنعت الحدث نائب من جيل جي او زاد
واخر ينتخب في التسعين من عمره وماريلاند
تصالحت مع تاريخها وانتخبت حاكما اسود
لم يحقق الجمهوريون كلما وعدوا به خاصه
منهم ولم يخسر ديمقراطيون كل ما كان يجب
ان يخسروه هذا هو ملخص نتائج انتخابات
التجديد النصفي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى الان الانتخابات كان من
المفترض انها تدور حول هذين الرجلين
الرئيس الحالي
وسلفه دونالد ترامب لكن مره اخرى تثبت
الانتخابات الامريكيه انها لعبه معقده بل
معقده للغايه اكبر من الحسابات ومن
الاستطلاعات واكبر حتى منها بين الرجل
[موسيقى]
ونبدا بالنتائج المتاحه حتى الان اختلفت
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه في حصه كل حزب في
مجلس النواب شبكه سي ان ان افادت بحصول
الجمهوريين على مئتين ثلاثه مقاعد مقابل
186 مقعدا للديمقراطيين وبالنسبه في مجلس
الشيوخ افادت سي ان ان بان الجمهوريين
يتقدمون ب 49 مقعدا مقابل 48
الديمقراطيين اما قناه فوكس نيوز اشارت
الى ان الجمهوريين حصلوا في مجلس النواب
على ثلاثه مقاعد مقابل 176
لديمقراطيين الارقام تتضارب بين حين واخر
بحسب الفتاه الاعلاميه وبالنسبه لمجلس
الشيوخ فالنتيجه حسب ماكس نيوز ايضا هي 49
مقعدا للجمهوريين مقابل 48
للديموقراطيين وبعد الاعلان عن جوله اعاده
رسميه في جورجيا في ديسمبر المقبل سيتاجل
حسم مجلس الشيوخ على الاغلب حتى ذلك
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
الحديثه في هذه الانتخابات الشرسه تنفسيه
اولها انه لا توجد موجه حمراء عكس توقعات
الجميع
المصريانو في ولايه بنسلفانيا في مجلس
الشيوخ ومنصب الحاكم على التوالي لكن جي
دي فانز فاز في سباق مجلس الشيوخ في ولايه
اوهايو
[موسيقى]
النقطه الثانيه المفاجاه الديمقراطيه كانت
ديمقراطيون على يقين من انهم سيتعرضون
للهزيمه لدرجه ان بعض الشخصيات الحزبيه
مثل حاكم كاليفورنيا جافاني يوسون بدا
اللوم قبل بدي الانتخابات لكن بدلا من ذلك
احتفظ الديمقراطيون بشكل غير متوقع بمقاعد
مجلس النواب من فرجينيا الى تكساس وحقق
انتصارات مريحه في مجلس الشيوخ كانت موضعه
كما هو الحال في نيو هامستر النقطه
الثالثه تدور حول ان الجمهوريين في مجلس
النواب ستكون لديهم مشاكل في المستقبل
فعيمه الاقليه الحالي في مجلس النوابتي
سيجدو نفسه مواجهه من موجه خطيره مع
اليمنيين داخل حسبه سيصعب على الرجل
الموائمه بين منصبه الجديد رئيسا لمجلس
وبين دعوات جمهوريه يمنيه انتقاميه من
بيدن من انطوني فاوتشي العالم الذي اصبح
وجه كوزيت في الولايات المتحده والعالم
كما ان فوز حاكم فلوريدا دي سانتوس الساحق
يصلي الضوء على منافسته دونالد ترامب في
انتخابات 20 24 في ضوء الدفعه المعنويه
الهائله التي اكتسبها طبعا انت رشح الرجل
لاحقا
[موسيقى]
النقطه الاهم ان العديد من المرشحين
الجمهوريين البارزين الذين دعموا ادعاءات
ترامب بشان التزوير الانتخابي خسروا
سباقاتهم ففي ولايه بنسلفانيا تعرض
مصريانو احد اكثر المرشحين التطرفا لهزيمه
النكراء اما في مشجن فخسرت منظره مؤامره
كريستينا كرامه وحلها لشغل منصب وزيره
خارجيه الولايه ولكن نظرا لحقيقه ان رفض
الانتخابات اصبح امرا شائعا جدا في الحزب
الجمهوري فمن المرجح ان يظل يشكل قوه
كبيره
[موسيقى]
لم اتوقع
ابداعات الحمراء الى اللون الازرق لكننا
فعلنا ما احتجنا الى القيام به واجرينا
تلك النقاشات عبر كل واحده من تلك
المقاطات وليلى ساكون سيناتور القادم من
بنسلفانيا
سنلقي نظره تاريخيه سريعه الان على
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه لنرى ماذا
تقول لنا دروس التاريخ يعاني الحزب الحاكم
بشكل دائم تقريبا من خسائر في الانتخابات
النصفيه وبالنسبه لبيض والديمقراطيين في
مجلس النواب كان احتماليه الاحتفاظ
بالسلطه في المجلس ضعيفه جدا اصلا فمنذ
عام
1906 كانت هناك ثلاث فترات نصفيه فقط حصل
فيها حزب الرئيس على الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب حدث ذلك في عام
1934 عندما كانت البلاد ما تزال تكافح
الكساد انذاك ثم في عام 98 عندما كانت
الولايات المتحده مدعومه باقتصاد متصاعد
والاخيره عام 2002 عندما حصل الرئيس جورج
بوش الابن على نسبه تاييد عاليه وسط
الشعور بالوحده الوطنيه بعد هجمات ال 11
من سبتمبر هناك احاديث همم تصلنا من ترامب
الان يقول ان انتخابات التجديد النصفي
كانت نصرا كبيرا جدا لنا على عكس ما هو
متوقع نستمع الى ما يقوله الى جورجيا الى
جورجيا اذا ثم نتابع مع ترامب نستمع الى
ما يجري هناك
وهو امر ملهم طبعا الامر يتعلق بالكثير من
الناس اللي يتحقق ذلك اذا نود ان يسني
اولا على فريق الانتخابات مكتب بقياده
بلايك
مدير الانتخابات
وكذلك فرز الاصوات فيما يتعلق
لدينا فواتير مذهله في مراكز
اختيار همم كان هناك همم حوالي 45 ثانيه
لكل الناخب هذه سرعه سمحت
بالانتظار لضيقتي دقيقتين فقط في الولايه
لدي صور تظهر ذلك
قراته على شبكه الانترنت بانه هناك شخص
كان يريد ان يمتحني هذا النظام
الذهاب الى مراكز الاقتراع وكنا همم
علمتني شاحنته الكثير من المياه ولم يجد
الكثير من التوابير وقال ان النظام
انه ليس هناك اي توابير في الشمس اذا امرا
مذهل ان ارى هذا النوع من الاستجابه واكد
لك النتائج الجيده التي حصلنا عليها ندرك
ان هذا الشعور منتشر في الولايات وفنا
للمقاطعه والناخبين ايضا الذين استفادوا
بي الانتخاب المبكر وقد حكموا الارقام
بالنسبه
للتصويت عبر البريد
وخلال الانتخابات النصفيه
وقد انجزنا العمل بعد ساعه ثانيه يوم
الاربعاء همم اقل من عشره الاف
خارج عدد المراكز يوم الاثنين في
الرابعه
همم فزناه طبعا همم واود ان اشكر سكي همم
التي
اه خسرت واود ان او اثني هنا على من يعترف
بالهزيمه
ويحاول مره اخرى اذا رغب في ذلك هناك سباق
في دولتنا سوف تنتقل في السادس من ديسمبر
وهو السباق
العضو الشيوخ بين براين
التحضير لدوله الاعاده هذه هو المقاطعه
تستعد لذلك بعض الامور الخاصه
الناخبون يمكن ان يحصلوها بطاقات الاقتران
من الان حتى يوم الاثنين
همم 28 نوفمبر
اه هناك من يستطيع ان يحصل على بطاقات
الاقتراع وهناك اشخاص في الخامسه والستين
الذين بحقهم ان يحصلوا هذه البطاقات
انتخاب المبكر الذي ان يبدا في 28 نوفمبر
في جميع المقاطات
مشاهدينا الكرام من المؤتمر الصحفي
لمسؤوليه الانتخابات في ولايه جورجيا حيث
ستجرى انتخابات الاعاده في السادس من
ديسمبر المقبل بين رافاييل من الحزب
الديمقراطي الذي حصل على نحو 49.4% من
النتائج المقارنه
فاصل خمسه بالمئه اوليفر الذي حصل فقط على
اثنين فاصل واحد بالمئه اذا المنافسه
محتدمه جدا في جورجيا بانتظار جوله
الاعاده اذا النتائج ست تاخر حتى حسن من
فاز وامسك بمجلس الشيوخ ولو ان تقدم واضحا
في مجلس النواب الى ان تعلم ان نتيجه
النهائيه يبقى انه ان المؤكد ان بيدن سيطر
للتفاوض كثيرا من الان فصاعدا مع مجلسي
الشيوخ والنواب تحت قبه الكونجرس بعد
الانتخابات لتمرير المشاريع التي وعد بها
الامريكيه ولا شك ان الاوضاع السياسيه في
الولايات المتحده خلال العامين المقبلين
ستكون صاخبه بين الحزبين خصوصا وان
الديمقراطيين يرون انهم تمكنوا من التصدي
لموجه صعود الجمهوريين او الموجه الحمراء
التي لم تحصل كما اشرناه
خصوصا مع اعتبار ديمقراطيين الفوز بمقعد
ولايه بنسلفانيا انتصارا كبيرا وتحولا في
الانتخابات والفضل بذلك لاوباما وبايدن مع
تركيزهم المكثف على مقعد الولايه الحسم
[موسيقى]
باتمان
اذا تقدم جمهوري دون انتصار ساحق وتراجع
ديمقراطي دون هزيمه النكراء شبكه مراسلينا
الان معنا من واشنطن لتشرح لنا كيف او
ماذا يعني ذلك حقيقه على الارض من خلال
الجهات التي قاموا بالتغطيه فيها امس ومن
خلال النتائج المعلنه حتى الان على الاقل
من واشنطن مراسله العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
من نيفادا مراسله العربيه ريتا سليمان ومن
جورجيا مراسل العربيه حسين الطوب اهلا بكم
جميعا وابدا معك ناديه واريد ان اعرف منك
الى اي مدى يمكن ان نلتزم حتى الان بهذا
العنوان العريض الذي يعني تحدثنا عنه
الاحد كبير واريد ان اضيف بان العنوان
المشابه هو ان الديمقراطيون حرموا
الجمهوريين من فوز كاسح كما كان متوقع كنا
نقول بان الجمهوريه سيفوزون في مجلس
النواب لانها عمليه حسابيه اولا خمس مقاعد
فقط هي ورقم ضئيل جدا للجمهوريين يعني ليس
برقم كبير حتى يستطيع ان يحققوا هذا الفوز
الكاسح عاده عن اعاده رسم الدوائر
الانتخابيه كانت في صالح الجمهوريه لكن
عمليه وجود كيف المقاس على رئاسه مجلس
النواب بدلا من الوجه المعروف وهو ناسي
فلوسي المقربه من الرئيس والمخدره التي
كانت تستطيع ان تمرر اي مشروع قرار في
مجلس النواب سيصعب حياه الرئيس لكن البيت
الابيض يتنفس السعداء لانه كما ذكر كان
هناك في الواقعه قراءه دقيقه جدا لكل ماذا
اكلته قبل ان ينظم اليك طاهر قبل قليل
التحليل في الواقع لما يحدث في الانتخابات
الامريكيه همم بانه بالفعل الرئيس بايدين
سيكون امامه متحدث لكن
الديمقراطيين يشعرون بالرضا بانه الخساره
ان تكون كبيره بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ يمكن
ان اتحدث عن همم جورج فقط يعني اذا حسمت
الليله الانتخابات في امازون وفي نيفادا
واحده منهم لصالح الديمقراطيين وهي ارزونا
ونفاذ لصالح الجمهوريه نتحدث عن اعاده في
الانتخابات طبعا هذه الاحسان يطلع لنا
اكثر همم في العاده ستكون لصالح
الديمقراطيه ونعود همم يعني عوده على
البدء بمعنى بان 50 50 طبعا نائبه الرئيس
تحسن الصوت الفارق لصالح الديمقراطين في
الاغلبيه اذا لم يتغير المشهد كثير في
مجلس الشيوخ وهذا يعتبر نصرا لديموقراطيين
لماذا لانه الشعار الذي رفع في هذه
الانتخابات هو الاقتصاد هو التضخم هو
ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات والطاقه هو هجوم
على الرئيس بايدن بعد الخروج من ازمه
كورونا وانفاق مليارات الدولارات يبدو بان
الناخب الامريكي همم نوعا ما اقتنع بما
قاله بيدن واوباما وغيرهم من قياده الحزب
الديمقراطي الذين قالوا بان الديمقراطيه
في خطر بان هناك مجموعه تنتمي الى ما تسمى
بالماجا وهو الشاعر الذي يطرحه ترامب تريد
ان تختطف الاسس التي بنيت عليها الولايات
المتحده وقت تشك في نزاهه الانتخابات اذا
لم تكون هناك ديمقراطيه لن يكون هناك
اقتصاد وكان سيء او كان جيد من الاخر
المعلومات التي حصل عليها حسين الطوب الان
خاصه فيما يجري عنده حسين الكلمه لك الان
تحيه لك طالب طبعا
طاهر عفوا اييه جوله الاعاده نحن ذاهبون
اليها في السادس من ديسمبر كما كان متوقعا
وكما تحدث المسؤول هنا في جورجيا همم
سكرتير الولايه قال ان هناك 20,000 صوت لم
تحتسب بعد ولكن حتى لو تم فرزها فهي لن
تؤثر على النتيجه الحاليه الموجوده اها
سبب هذه الجمله طبعا هو التنافساد بين
المرشحين الرئيسيين ووجود ايضا مرشح ثالث
هو تشيز اوليفر عن الحزبريتاري الذي حصل
على اثنين فاصله واحد بالمئه من الاصوات
ما حرم
كلوكر من الوصول الى عتبه 50% لهذا سبب
القانون جورجيا كما هو بات معروفا ينص على
ان من لا ي- اا اذا لم يحصل احد المرشحين
على 50% فتحنا ذاهبون الى جوله اعاده همم
الان همم سيجري في السادس من هو في
الحقيقه تكرار لسيناريو الذي حدث عام 2020
والذي فاز همم خلاله هناك في جوله الاعاده
ايضا ولكن الاوضاع مختلفه هذه المره
الديمقراطيون وورناد كانوا خلال حملتهم
الانتخابيه همم في موقع الدفاع عن عن عن
انفسهم وعن في حملتهم ضد موجه الهجوم الذي
التي قادها الجمهوريون مستغلين وضع التضخم
وضع الاقتصاد وارتفاع الجريمه هنا في
جورجيا لهذا السبب الوضع مختلف ولكن بعض
المحللين وسيما من الديمقراطيين يرجحون
همم ان يفوز اسباب عديده منها ان همم
في الجهه المقابله همم
الحاكم الذي فاز همم اعيد انتخابه همم
لولايه جورج هو جمهوري لن يكون على لائحه
الاقتراع وهو همم ساهم بزياده اعداد
الناخبين بالنسبه لهرش الواقع ساعده خلال
هذه الحمله همم ثانيا اذا كان بالفعل هناك
همم مناصفه همم تم حسب الولايات الاخرى
وكان هناك منصه بقينا ديمقراطين وجمهوريين
همم الاغلبيه او بالاحرف التصوير سيكون
لصالح المرشح الديمقراطي هنا برنار ولكن
تاريخيا تشدر الاشاره انه منذ عام 1960
وحتى عمل في 2020 كان هناك احد عشر جوله
اعاده فاذا بها الجمهوريه سبعه مرات
التاريخ في الحقيقه حسب لغه الارقام يلعب
لصالح الجمهوريين ولكن الاوضاع الحاليه
تختلف اللي جمال لا ننسى التغير
الديموغرافي في جورجيا خلال عشر سنوات اثر
كثيرا لم تعد جورجيا معقل الجمهوريين كما
كانت من قبل كانت ولايه حمراء الان راينا
مدحت حدث عام 2020 عندما فاز بها مرشحات
همم عن الحزب الديمقراطي على مقادي مجلس
الشيوخ اعطت اصواتها في مجمع الانتخابي
همم تحولت الى ولايه زرقاء واحده من
الاسباب بطبيعه الحال كانت ايضا كما قلنا
التغير الديموغرافي والدوره الكبيره الذي
لعبته السيسي ابرامز التي كانت مرشحها
لمنصب الحاكم في تحفيز اخرين من اصول
افريقيه على المشاركه وعلى انهاء عقود من
المشاركه السلبيه بانتظار هذا همم
دوله الاعاده في هذه العوامل همم جميعها
همم اتحول الان الى ريتا سليمان والمتوقع
لنيفادا ريتا
نيفادا الان تجري حساباتها النهائيه خاصه
مع تقدم طفيف للمرشحه الجمهوريه ادم في
نيفادا عن المرشح عن مجلس الشيوخ على
منافساته الديمقراطيه كافه
مع العلم انه كورتاز ماستو تقدمت في ولايه
كلارك كرانتي هذه الولايه التي تحوي على
75% من همم التجمع السكاني في ولايه
نيفادا ولكن
كاونتي همم
كان هناك تقدم كبير اللي هي المرشح
الجمهوري ما جعله يتقدم ولو بيهانش قليل
على المرشحه الديمقراطيه همم الوضع هنا
كان متوقع ولكن باختلاف الاوضاع التي لا
زالت حتى اللحظه همم غير محسومه في
اريزونات وما يبقى ايضا في الحسابات هنا
في نيفادا بان هذه المره الاولى في هذه
المحافظه يتم اعتماد ما يعرف بيونيفرسال
فوت ميل اي همم
الاقتراع من الخارج وبالتالي هذه الاصوات
همم تحسم الان ويتم احتسابها الان لهذا لم
تعلن النتيجه الرسميه النهائيه حتى اللحظه
كل هذه الاخبار معك ريتا سليمان من نيفادا
مراسله العربيه ومع حسين التوضنين جورجيا
بانتظار جوله الاعاده هناك ومع ناديه
البلبيسي همم مراسلات العربيه من واشنطن
كذلك شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا على كل هذه
المعلومات تحياتي اليكم
[موسيقى]
بكون معكم للمتابعه ايضا
من قال انه لا يستطيع الجيزي او زد تحت
قبه الكاميرا
[موسيقى]
العراقين اما بالنسبه للرجال 53%
هم من الاربعه والاربعين بالمئه
للجمهوريين ننتقل الى الفئات العمريه
الديمقراطيون نالو اصواتا اكثر عبر الفئات
العمريه بين ثمانيه عشر عاما و39 عاما
وبفارق كبير نسبيا التقارب بين الحزبين
كان في الفئه العمريه من من هم في
الاربعينات من اعمارهم ليعود الجمهوريون
في التفوق عندما يتعلق الامر بالناخبين من
50 عاما واكثر
[موسيقى]
الان الى التقسيمات العرقيه والاثنيه
57% من الناخبين البيض صوتوا للجمهوريين
على الجانب الاخر 82% من المواطنين من
اصول افريقيه ذهبت اصواتهم للديمقراطيين
اما الناخبون من اصول اللاتينيه فاختاري
ثمانيه من كل 10 منهم مرشحا ديمقراطيا
تصنيف اخر لاستطلاع
كان التعليم الجمهوريون نالوا اصواتا اكثر
من قبل مؤيديهم الذين حاضوا بجزء من
التعليم الجامعي ولم يكملوه اضافه لحمالات
شهاده الثانويه او اقل اخيرا في هذا الجزء
نتحدث عن المجتمعات المحليه سكان المدن
الذين صوتوا بنسبه تجاوزت 60%
للديموقراطيين وتعادلت تقريبا النسبه بين
الحسبين بالنسبه لسكان الضواحي والارياف
اما بالنسبه للبلدات صغيره والمناطق
النائيه فقد
وسكانها لجمهوريين بنسب وصلت لضعف النسبه
التي حصل عليها مرشح لحزب الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
في استطلاعها ملفات مهمه للناخبين اثنان
من كل ثلاثه ناخبين جمهوريين كان الملف
الاقتصادي يدافعهم للتصويت في مكانه
النسبه
33% عند الناخبين الديمقراطيين التغيير
المناخي والاجهاض ملفان كان لهما مكان
متقدمه عند الديمقراطيين خاصه بسبب ملف
الاجهاض وقرار المحكمه العليا بتقيد
عمليات الاجهاض في الولايات المتحده على
الجانب الاخر كان ملف الهجره مهما جدا
للناخبين الجمهوريين ونال اهتمام 87% منهم
لكنه هناك ملفا واحدا حدث فيه التقارب وهو
ملف الجريمه
56% من الجمهوريين اعتبره مهما في حين وصل
الاهتمام بين الديمقراطيين لاربعين في
المئه
اخيرا بعد ان انتهت الانتخابات وبدات
عمليات الفرز باستثناء عمليات الاعاده
طبعا لاحقا هذا السؤال وجه للناخبين هل
تثق بشكل كبير بان الاصوات سيتم عدها بشكل
دقيق
77% من الناخبين الديمقراطيين اجابوا بنعم
وقبل 20% فقط على الطرف المقابل ومن بين
الجمهوريين 55% قالوا انهم واثقون نسبيا
اخيرا انعدام الثقه الجزئيه او الكلي كان
كبيرا لدى الجمهوريين عندما قال 86% منهم
انهم لا ثقه لهم بالنتائج مقابل 10% فقط
بين الديمقراطيين في كل الاحوال لا يبدو
التشكيك كبيرا في عمليات الاقتراع او
النتائج باستثناء اريزونا و- جورجيا حتى
الان جورجيا التي ستجرى فيها عمليات
الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر معنا من
واشنطن الان الخبير في شان الامريكي ولا
علاقات الدوليه الاستاذ عباس اهلا بك معنا
استاذ ايهاب الى اي مدى يمكن ان نقول بان
هذه الانتخابات
مهما كانت خصوصياتها الا انها همم لم تشد
عن قاعده الانتخابات او جميع الانتخابات
السابقه من حب بحكم العوامل والمحددات
التي يختار على اساسها الناخب او من حيث
المعركه حاميه الوطيس بين الحزبين
يعلم بحضرتك استاذ طارق بكل المشاهدين
اينما كانوا يعني الانتخابات طبعا هذا
العام لها خصوصياتها بسبب ما سببها من
احداث منذ عامين والخروج المذوي الحزب
الجمهوري من كل السلطات التنفيذيه الكبرى
نتحدث عن البيت الابيض والكونجرسيد همم في
الواقع خلال العامين الماضيين ايضا اداره
لم يكن لها هذا الزخم في اداره الملفات
الداخليه والخارجيه الذي يجعلها تروق لكل
الامريكيين بمختلف اطيافتهم بمن فيهم طبعا
الجمهوريون لانه همم بصحيح الجمهوريين
ينتخبون الجمهوريين ولكن في نهايه المطاف
اذا كانت الاداره اداره البلاد تدار بشكل
يعجبه فانهم ربما لن يكونوا غير متحمسين
للتغيير بالشكل المطلوب لكن همم ما حدث
خلال العامين الماضيين والاتهامات الكثيره
التي وجهت للديمقراطيه الامريكيه من قبل
الجمهوريين ادت الى ان تكون هناك كره ثلج
تك ليه محاوله اعاده الجمهوريين الى
المشهد وهو ما نجحوا فيه بشكل او باخر
اليوم يتقدمون في مجلس النواب ولديهم تقدم
بمقعد واحد في مجلس الشيوخ ربما يؤدي في
نهايه المطاف الى تقدم والحصان
ولكن دون تسونامي كان متوقعا ما الذي
حرمهم من ذلك باعتقادك اين وقع الاداء
الديمقراطي الناجح بعيون الناخب حتى حرم
الجمهوريين من هذا المد او هذا التسونامي
وايضا بالعكس اين حقق الجمهوريون نتائج
ايجابيه على اي اصعده حتى
ادوا او ادوا الى تراجع الديمقراطيين ولو
دون همم هزيمتهم بالكامل
يعني انا شخصيا اضع عنوان العناد السياسي
هو المتحكم في مزاج الناخب الاميركي اليوم
فكره العناد السياسي من قبل الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين بمعنى انا ديمقراطيين صحيح
لديهم ملفات مهمه ويطرحونها بكل شغف
ولديهم ااا جمهور عريض يوافق عليها كمسائل
الاجهاض والمناخ الى اخره الا ان هناك همم
العناد السياسي الذي جاء مع فكره الاعتداء
على الديمقراطيه في عام 2021 او في 2020
والتي تم تسويقها بشكل جيد جدا من قبل
الديمقراطيين
وجعلت المواطن الامريكي الديمقراطي وغير
الديمقراطي والجمهوري يعني المواطن الايدل
المعتدل نيوترون يخاف ويشعر بقاله الشديد
بسبب احتماليه ان تكون الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه في خطر هذا على الجانب
الديمقراطي لذلك هو ذهب لصناديق الاختراع
من اجل هذه الفكره اكثر من الافكار الاخرى
التي هي ما تقليه جيده ايضا في المقابل
الجمهوريين لديهم هذا الجرح العميق منذ
عام 2020 الانتخابات الماضيه باعتقادهم
بان الانتخابات سرقت منهم وباعتقادم بان
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كان يجب ان
يكون هو الرئيس الحالي للولايات المتحده
وايضا الملفات التي اديرت من وجهه نظرهم
بشكل سيء جدا على المستوى الداخلي ملف
الاغتصاب ملف النفط ملف التضخم ملف حتى
مكافحه التضخم الذي لم ينجح فيه جو بايدن
ولا السيده جنتيل وزيره الخزانه برفع
الفائده المستمر همم وايضا المعالم
المستوى الخارجي بالملفات التي همم نعلمها
جميعا على راسها الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وعدم تقديم واشنطن اي حلول دبلوماسيه في
هذا الاطار ودعم لا متناهي بعشرات
المليارات الدولارات لاوكرانيا اتى على
حساب جيب المواطن الامريكي هذه النقطه
تحديدا اعتقد انها ادت همم يعني شجعت
الديمقرا الجمهوريين
الذهاب الى صناديق الاقتراع بشكل كبير
بجانب فكره انهم خسروا الانتخابات السابقه
كما سبق الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب طبعا
بسبب التزوير وهمم يعني الامور التي
نعلمها جميعا وافقس نيوز تقول الان انها
مقاعد الجمهوريين ارتفعت في مجلس النواب
الى مئتين واربعه مقاعد ايهاب عباس الخبير
في شان الامريكي والعلاقات الدوليه من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
حتى الان من نتائج هل يمكن القول ان ترامب
في هذه الانتخابات لان كثيرين ممن دعامهم
خسروا سباق الانتخابي قبل اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع الى ترامب عن مقدار الفضل الذي
يجب ان يحصل عليه عقب النتائج فقال اعتقد
انه اذا فازوا يجب ان احصل على كل الفضل
اما اذا خسره فلا ينبغي ان انام على
الاطلاق
تحدث الرئيس الخامس والاربعون للولايات
المتحده لكننا اسماء في الحزب الجمهوريه
بدات الترم الثاني
في حدوث المد المد الاحمر في الوقت نفسه
كان الفائز الاكبر هذا الشخص
المنافس الرئيس لترامب في ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري عام 20 و24
نقطه وجعل فلوريدا اكبر ولايه متارجحه في
امريكا سابقا معقلا للجمهوريين في خطاب
النصر الذي القاه
وضعت المحن قويا فيه بانه سيواجه ترامب في
20 24 حتى ان بعضا من المحللين اباته
يرجحون ان انتخابات 20 24 ستكون التنافسا
بين بيضا وديسمتس
ليتن
لكن من ما لا شك فيه ان منكري الانتخابات
الرئاسيه 2020 من الجمهوريين بالطبع حقق
انتصارات جيده لكنهم يعانون ايضا من
انتكاسات كبيره خصوصا مع اعراب الناخبين
عن ثقه اكبر في ان الانتخابات في ولايتهم
جرت بشكل عادل ودقيق فقال حاول ثمانيه من
كل عشره ناخبين انهم موافقون جدا او الى
حد ما من ان الانتخابات في ولايتهم ستكون
عادله ودقيقه في المقابل لعبت انتخابات
الثلاثاء دورا في تزايد قلق الامريكيين
بشان الديمقراطيه في بلادهم قال ما يقرب
من سبعه من كل 10 ناخبين ان الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه مهدده جدا او الى حد ما وفقا
لاستطلاعات الراي المبكر الذي باشرته شركه
معنى من واشنطن هبه القدس مديره مكتب
جريده الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن اهلا بك
معنا الاستاذه هبه مره جديده على شاشه
العربيه عندما يتم الحديث عن تهديد
الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده لابد ان
يكون هناك مفاهيم خاصه بهذه البلاد عندما
يتعلق الموضوع بتعريف الديمقراطيه وبتعريف
التهديد الذي تتعرض له ما المقصود
ارسله رسائل قويه الى الناخبين الامريكيين
خلال الايام الماضيه على خلفيه ايضا
الهجوم الذي تعرض له زوج سيده نانسي فلوسي
والذي اثاره مخاوف كثيره حول الصعود العنف
او الاستقطاب الحزبي الذي يؤدي بانصار ما
جاء او اجعله امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى
وانصار الرئيس ترامب الى موجه جديده من
العنف ولا زالت في الاذهان همم احداث
الاعتداء على الكابيتال في سته يناير
الماضي وبالتالي كان المخاوف لدى
الامريكيين من عوده هذا الجدل
حول مصداقيه ونزاهه الانتخابات الامريكيه
امام انظار الناخب الامريكي بشكل كبير وهو
يحرص على ترسيخ هذه القيم الديمقراطيه
والثقه في
الانتخاب الامريكي والثقافي النظام
القضائي وفي السلطات التشريعيه والتنفيذيه
والقضائيه وهي الاسس التي تقوم عليها
الديمقراطيه داخل الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي كان الديمقراطيون ناجحون للغايه
في استغلال هذه النقطه خاصه ان
الاستطلاعات كما اشرت كانت تشير الى ان 70
بالمئه من الامريكيين متخوفون من اين تمضي
الديمقراطيه ومصار الديمقراطيه في خطر همم
سواء خطر شديد او خطر الى حد
هل عدل الامريكيون باعتقادك في
بطاقات اقتراعهم في تصويطهم هذه المره من
المسار بمعنى الانجذاب الكبير الفرز
والاستقطاب الكبير الذي حصل في الفتره
الاخيره خاصه ايام الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب وما بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الماضيه همم يعني ذهبنا كثيرا الى اقصى
اليمين احيانا فيما يتعلق بجمهوريين
واحيانا ايضا كان هناك اتهامات
للديمقراطيين بالذهاب الى اقصى اليسار هل
عدل الامريكيون هذا المسار هذه المره
عادوا الامور الى وسطها
يبدو ذلك
تضخيم كبير لما يسمى بالظاهره الترابيه او
تاثير ونفوز الرئيس ترامب على ترجيح كافه
المرشحين الجمهوريون بشكل عام فهناك كان
هناك في هذا السباق اكثر من 300 مرشح
جمهوري على مستوى المقاطعه ومجلس النواب
ومجلس الشيوخ وغيرها من المناصب داخل
الولايات
وجميعهم كانوا يؤيدون دعاوى الرئيس ترامب
في تزوير الانتخابات لكن يبدو ان ميل
الناخب الامريكي الى الاعتدال والى تصحيح
هذا المسار باعطاء ديم مليون همم باعطاء
المرشحون الديموقراطيون الاصوات بشكل كبير
بما ادى الى انحصار ما يسمى بالموقع
الحمراء قد اعاد التوازن واعاد الثقه الى
حد ما في مصداقيه ونزاهه الانتخابات
الامريكيه من جانب اخر لم تؤثر انخفاض
شعبيه الرئيس بيضا في سحب البساط من
المرشحين الديمقراطيطي كان هناك قوه كبيره
في مواجهه هذه الماده او الموجه الحمراء
الجمهوريه كان هناك قوه لدى الديمقراطيين
في المنافسه بشده همم المرجح الان ان مجلس
النواب سيكون في قبضه الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
لكن الامال كبيره على ما سيتم في همم
الولايات الثلاثه المتبقيه في صفقات
الشيوخ وهي اا الى الانفاده واريزونا
وجورج بعد ان حسمت همم
بعد ان حسمت في
وسكانسنر جونسون لكن ال- ال- الامور اذا
حققت ااا اذا حقق الجمهوريون انتصارا في
نيفادا
واريزونا فيبدوا بذلك انه قد حصلوا على
مقادهم اضافه الى واحد الى 48 مقعد الى 49
مقعد حالي تم همم حافظ بهم وهذا سيحقق لهم
همم الانتصار والاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
حتى وان تمت جوله اعاده
اعاده همم الانتخاب في ولايه جورجيا وحسمت
لصالح الديمقراطين
قبه الكونجرس عموما في المجلسين في مجلس
النواب واقف وكذلك في مجلس الشيوخ
جزيلا على هذه القراءه واعذروني على
المقاطعه ستذهب القدسيه مديره مكتب جريده
الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن من هناك تحيه اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا معركه شامبو لخوض
الرئاسه لن تكون مع الديمقراطيين فقط
سيضطر اولا لسحق الوحش الذي صنعوه بنفسه
اهلا بكم من جديد بعض المرشحين في
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه لم يفوزوا
فقط بل كسروا بعض الحواجز ودخلوا التاريخ
الامريكي نبدا من ولايه دلموند التي ولاول
مره ترسل امراه وهي باكا بالينت كممثله
بمجلس النواب ولايه بانسلفانيا بدورها
اختارت لاول مره سيده من اصول افريقيه
كعضو بمجلس النواب وهي نائب سامر لي نبقى
مع الحالات الاولى ولايه الينوي سترسل
لمجلس النواب لاول مره سيده من اصول
اللاتينيه هي داليا راميز وحاله مشابهه
لكن في مجلس الشيوخ ولايه على باماما
اوصلت كيتي للمجلس لاول مره في تاريخ
الولايه الى الجنوب قليلا اختارت ولايات
اركانسو امراه كحاكمه لها وهي سيره هكبي
ساندرس المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض في عهد
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امراه اخرى
دخلت تاريخ ولايتها كاول حاكمه لها هي كيف
هوكول الحاكمه الحاليه للولايه لكنها وصلت
بالتعيين ويوم امس اصبحت الحاكمه المنتخب
الان ننتقل الى الفئات العمريه ماكس
والفروست دخل تاريخ الكونجرس كاسغر عضو
يصل المجلس في الخامسه والعشرين من عمره
وفي المقابل اعادت ولايات ايوان انتخابات
عضوي مجلس الشيوخ جاست لي مره اخرى
لاول مره عام 81 من القرن الماضي ويبلغ من
العمر الان 89 عاما لكن جرسلي لن يكون
اكبر اعضاء المجلس عمرا اثناء فتره خدمته
الرقم القياسي مسجل حتى اللحظه باسم سنه
الذي وصل لعمر مئه عام و29 يوما اثناء
عمله بمجلس الشيوخ
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 هي اللي جداريه هذه
الطبمان في ولايه ميريلاند على صوت هذه
الامريكيه من اصول الافريقيه قبل عقود مضت
لتناديه بالغاء الرقه كافحت لانقاذ بني
جلدتها من نيل العبوديه وكافحت بعدها
الانتزاع حقوق المراه ودفعت الثمن غاليا
اليوم وبعد 200 عام من ولادتها طبعت
صورتها على الورقه من فئه العشرين دولارا
لكن مكافاتها الاكبر تحققت في الصوره تمد
يدها لمساعده المظلومين لكن من سيمد يده
ليلتقط يدها الان
وسمور الحاكم جديد للولايه التي ولدت فيها
ماريلاند الحاكم الان اسود البشر
وفي تصريح اليوم لم نفعل شيئا بعد لقد
بدانا المعركه للتو التصريح هو لحاكم
فلوريدا المحتفظ بمنصبه جون ديسانتس يعطي
الفائز اشارات عديده للناخبين على انه
سيكون خصما شرسا في انتخابات الجمهوريين
للترشح للانتخابات الرئاسه المقبله طبعا
لن يفوت هذا الامر على عراب ديسانتس
الرئيس السابق دونال جامب اذ حذره بشكل
واضح ستؤذي نفسك بشده ان ترشحت انتخابات
20 24 اذا ستشهد حربا ضاريه بين الحزبين
لكنها اولا ستشهد حرب تكسير عظام جمهوريه
جمهوريه
وفي فيديو اليوم الجيل زد او زي ذلك الجيل
الذي اتى بعد الالفيه بين منتصف التسعينات
ومنتصف العقد الاول من الالفيه الثانيه من
الالفيه الثالثه في الواقع ذلك الجيل الذي
يضيع اغلب وقته مع التكنولوجيا ويكيف
حياته معها ذلك الجيل الذي يبدو حائرا
ومشتتا باستمرار يعمل في وظيفه مرموقه
بالنهار وكسائقي اجره في الليل لا يملك
المال اللازم كي يخوض معارك السياسه ولا
يفهم معاييرها الحقيقه هذا الجيل الذي لا
يتخطى الخمسه والعشرين عاما او الاعوام ال
25 بدله ممثل في الكونغرس ماكس والفروست
الذي انتزع مقعدا في مجلس النواب عن
فلوريدا بعد منافسه مع سياسيا وخضرا يبلغ
ضعف عمره الجنسيه يفعل اذا كل ما يقال انه
لا يستطيع ان يفعله يفعل ذلك ولكن على
طريقه